I alluded to this yesterday on the
members-only bonus show that there's
growing concern among Donald Trump
staffers about how they can avoid
confusing him and the extent to which
Donald Trump is confusable is a growing
area of concern for the people that are
working around him on a daily basis one
such example is that Donald Trump's
aides were looking for Twitter to put in
place a 15-minute delay on Donald
Trump's tweets such that they could
maybe be canceled or fixed or modified
before they go out I'll get to that in a
moment but there's a really interesting
storyline that's growing from reporting
by Politico and others about how Donald
Trump is being kept away from certain
people simply to avoid confusing him and
it's like dealing with a 9 year old kid
and in fact I would argue it's actually
like dealing with a cognitively limited
nine-year-old kid here's an example
shortly after ukrainian president
zalenski was elected an actual ukraine
expert the whistleblower that we now
know as Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN
man who's at the center of a lot of
controversy right now VIN Minh was set
to brief Donald Trump about zalenski why
well it made sense VIN Minh is an actual
Ukraine expert Trump needs to know
what's going on in Ukraine it makes
sense to have an expert briefed Trump
about that issue
Trump staffers at the last second told
VIN Minh you know what don't show up
Trump will become confused by your
presence because Donald Trump is under
the impression that this other guy kept
patel is actually the expert on Ukraine
now what's hilarious is that Kasia
Patel is not an expert on Ukraine Patel
was a Devin Nunez staffer from Devon
newness of course the completely bogus
and and disgusting and depraved
Republican Congressmen kept patel has no
expertise on Ukraine he has no knowledge
on Ukraine but Donald Trump believed
that Kashia Patel was the expert on
Ukraine and staffer said you know if
vind Minh shows up to talk to Trump
about Ukraine Trump will become confused
so they tell VIN Minh don't show up even
though VIN Minh is actually the Ukraine
expert this is tragic this is sad but
it's also disturbing when it comes to in
order to avoid confusing Trump
people who aren't actually our real
experts on subject matter are being
chosen to brief Trump and the real
subject matter experts are being kept
out of the entire thing here's another
example it's the Twitter thing which I
mentioned Donald Trump's aides at one
point were considering asking Twitter to
effectively reprogram the way that the
platform works just for Donald Trump's
account - in state a fifteen minute
delay on Donald Trump's tweets this was
earlier in Trump's presidency and they
wanted to do it without Trump's
knowledge and what was going on is that
Donald Trump's tweeting was obviously so
problematic from day one and staffers
were struggling with how to manage it
Trump was obviously not going to allow
someone the power to okay or not okay
his tweets so the idea was let's
secretly go to Twitter and let's have
them put a fifteen minute delay on
Donald Trump's tweets and during those
15 minutes
staffers presumably would be able to
either edit tweets delete them talk
Trump out of them whatever the case may
be understand the scope of this where
Trump is so erratic in his behavior but
also react so negatively to any attempt
at controlling or modifying his behavior
that staff were looking at asking one of
the largest social media platforms in
the world to program in functionality
just for Donald Trump's account
specifically to avoid the embarrassment
and problems that Donald Trump's
tweeting was causing never mind by the
way how potentially abused the tool
could be imagine if you are one of Trump
staffers and you see that Donald Trump
writes a tweet and you've got 15 minutes
to act on that tweet and you know that
it's a tweet that could for example tank
the stock price of a publicly traded
company during those 15 minutes you
could go and short that stock to make a
financial gain windfall really from what
you now can predict pretty safely
because Donald Trump's tweets move the
markets will be an upcoming shift in a
share price it's dangerous it's stunning
that this is something that it would
they would even consider asking a
platform like Twitter to do
and the reality is something that we've
known for a long time the people around
Donald Trump have to treat the guy like
as I said a poorly behaved or even
cognitively limited kid despite the fact
that he is you know a wealthy 73 year
old white guy born with a silver spoon
in his mouth who has not ever known any
actual adversity in his entire life and
yet still believes that he is the
greatest victim of the unfairness of the
world as he constantly talks about witch
hunts and presidential harassment and
how unfairly he's treated by the media
it is like dealing with a kid that is
what staffers are increasingly
describing sad but dangerous as well
there's a new report that if true is the
most shocking revelation in the entire
jamaal khashoggi fiasco since its
inception and if this is actually true
it's actually arguably much worse than
the Ukraine scandal which is already a
major major scandal The Spectator is
reporting that whistleblowers can allege
with evidence that's whistleblowers
plural that Donald Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner personally gave the green
light personally okayed on the phone
with Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman to go ahead and arrest journalist
Jamal khashoggi who of course we know
after being arrested was killed and
dismembered at the Saudi Arabian
consulate in Istanbul Turkey the gravity
of this is is almost inconceivable two
of the whistleblowers out of the seven
that are involved generally in this
report from the spectator two of the
whistleblowers involved here reportedly
are in agreement about this and it is
apparently not just an assertion but one
of the two whistleblowers says that an
intercepted phone call that is in the
possession of Turkish and chaough
intelligence actually is the
conversation during which this took
place the phone call is reportedly
between Jared Kushner himself and
Mohammed bin Salman himself and I have
even more to discuss with this because
of something that I said
a little while back the existence of
this phone call is said to have been the
way that Turkish president air Dhawan
was able to convince or strongarm Donald
Trump into pulling troops from Syria now
this is still early but that allegation
is one that I hypothesized about at the
start of the syria fiasco and a lot of
people wrote to me saying David that is
baseless speculation and you are wrong
to do it well it's certainly speculative
this is an analysis and commentary show
and that's one of the things that we do
we speculate but there were reasons to
do that speculation primarily that there
was no sensible explanation for the
timing of Donald Trump's decision to
pull troops from Syria this is my clip
from three weeks ago and a lot of people
were angry with me for it take a listen
and then we start to speculate does Iran
have something so bad on the killing of
Jamal Khashoggi that if it were to get
out it would be even more devastating
that Donald Trump didn't do a damn thing
about it instead selling more weapons to
Saudi Arabia it's a possibility yeah
that is now exactly what is being
alleged that her Diwan has something so
bad on Trump that Trump's son-in-law
personally okayed to Mohammed bin Salman
the arrest of Jamal khashoggi in this
case which led to Koosh OGIS killing
that he was able to force Donald Trump
to pull troops out of Syria so there are
actually two scandals here and the
reporting that I'm seeing is mostly
about just one of those scandals so
scandal number one if indeed Jared
Kushner Trump's son-in-law unelected not
confirmed by the Senate an advisor to
Donald Trump if Jared Kushner personally
told Mohammed bin Salman to go ahead and
arrest a Washington Post journalist that
is a scandal of the highest degree we
are talking colloquially I'm not making
a legal argument I'm not a lawyer we are
talking colloquially about conspiracy to
commit murder although of course they'll
never be held accountable we know that
but it goes further than that if this
phone call being recorded
put Turkey in a position
to be able to strong-arm Donald Trump to
have hazard Lee pull troops from
northern Syria in direct contradiction
to what any of Donald Trump's generals
or the Pentagon or the State Department
were suggesting which led to the deaths
of Kurds it's leading to the possible
resurgence of Isis it is an absolute
travesty and a tragedy of foreign policy
and it is the complete subjugation of
the office of the presidency at our
expense for the benefit of foreign
governments now we have to be careful
here because this is one story from The
Spectator we want corroboration of the
story we eventually ideally will get the
actual whistleblower testimony on this
because it's not just if the story is
false if even some element of the story
is not exactly as described we already
know that the trumpets will jump all
over it as fake news as evidence of the
media's corruption and even if the story
is off by a fraction
they will discredit the entire thing but
the truth is the opposite if even a
fraction of this story is true if one
whistleblower says Kushner okayed the
arrest of jamal khashoggi instead of two
if turkey did strong-armed Trump on
troops in Syria using anything related
to Khashoggi if any element of this
story is true it is a scandal of the
highest order that I mean listen I'm
still trying to process the entire thing
and with scandal fatigue they all start
to sort of blend together but my
immediate impression is that this is
arguably bigger than any other scandal
of the Trump presidency because of the
gravity and disgusting vile nature of it
that is what is being alleged as of
right now by the time you listen to this
by the time you watch this maybe we will
know more in a week who knows what we
will know but this is number one not
very different from what we have
suspected for a very long time with
regard to the Turkish strong arming of
Trump and Jared Kushner is unelected he
was not confirmed by the Senate it is
the chrony istic nepotism that donald
trump I guess said he was going to
eliminate by draining the swamp and
blood a little all of that stuff it
hasn't happened it's worse than we could
have ever imagined one of the storylines
that's the
kind of being written about Republicans
in the 21st century is whether or not
Donald Trump's election in 2016
represents the beginning of a major
multi-decade downfall for the Republican
Party in the United States or not and we
don't know the answer yet the 2020
election is going to be a big part of it
but we already have some data points we
already had Democrats taking over
control of the house back in 2018 in the
midterms by one of the larger margins in
recent midterms anecdotally because they
ran you know the serial sex assault or
Roy Moore in Alabama Democrats took a
Senate seat in Alabama although it's
likely that they're going to give that
back in the 2020 election but then at
the state level there have been some
pretty major advancements and last night
there were a bunch of statewide
elections and Republicans got absolutely
crushed in some key places and it could
be I mean we don't know but it could be
a sign about what could happen in 2020
if we're ready to work but it always
assumes that we're ready to work so
let's go through some of these Kentucky
Kentucky's a very red state a Donald
Trump won by 30 points over Hillary
Clinton in 2016 in Kentucky Kentucky had
a Trump loving governor named Matt Bevin
a major Democratic Party victory has
taken place in Kentucky the Democratic
challenger Andy Beshear who was is I
guess for a little bit longer the
Attorney General of the state knocking
out the Republican governor this is
Kentucky this is not a blue or a purple
state it was a tiny margin just about
5,000 votes that's under 0.5% of the
vote but this is just a brutal loss not
just for Kentucky Republicans but also
for Trump because of what this race
represents now the immediate question
after these results came in last night
was if the Republican Kentucky governor
lost then maybe Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell Republican senator from
Kentucky could also lose in Kentucky in
2020 it's hard to say it's a very
different race McConnell is not as
unpopular as Bevin had become over the
last few months although McConnell is
not particularly popular
and there is actually more of a history
in Kentucky if you go back of having
Democratic governors and there is not a
similar a likewise history of having
Democratic senators so we'll see either
way McConnell is going to have to run a
campaign right he's gonna have to run a
real race against Amy McGrath who's
challenging him he's not going to be
able to just ignore the threat from her
that's a great race to work on by the
way if you live in Kentucky or even if
you don't eventually I'm sure there will
be phone banking opportunities so that's
Kentucky let's go from Kentucky to
Virginia in Virginia Democrats have
taken over control of both the Virginia
State House and the Virginia State
Senate they now are going to control the
entire state legislature they already
have a Democratic governor and Virginia
is looking more and more like a blue
state Democrats have been out of power
for 20 years in the Virginia House of
Delegates and they swept yesterday's
election so in Virginia Democratic
governor Ralph Northam Democratic House
and Democratic Senate incoming and
Virginia has been a sort of it's
interesting what's happened in Virginia
it's kind of sad actually they've been
held back at the state level from
adopting a lot of the policies that
other solidly blue states have adopted
that could now change with Democrats
taking over total control in Virginia so
that's a very good sign for Democrats
here's another one
Democrats have taken over control of
Mike Pence's hometown for the first time
in almost four decades now it's true
Columbus Indiana which most of you have
never heard of it's not a huge player on
the national political stage I I agree
with you but in terms of the trumpet's
element to this Mike Pence is Donald
Trump's vice president his home town has
voted for Democrats to take over control
of the City Council electing for
Democrats to the City Council Council
taking control for the first time there
in 38 years even when you look at some
of the races that Democrats lost last
night it still doesn't look good for
Republicans and I'll give you a really
interesting example out of Minnesota
which is the governor's race there when
you look at the results out of I'm sorry
out of a Mississippi not Minnesota
when you look at the Mississippi results
from yesterday you see that the
Republican incumbent lieutenant governor
Tate Reeves won defeating the Democratic
challenger Jim hood okay it's
Mississippi and a Republican one but
what does this really tell us well what
it tells us says this is one of the
reddest states in the country
Trump won it by 17 points in 2016 over
Hillary in the 2015 gubernatorial
election in Mississippi the Republican
won by 34 points and last night the
Republican only won by 6
turnout was up more than 70 percent
overall but Republican turnout was down
by 6 percent in this race that is
terrible news for Republicans heading
into 2020 and later on in the show we're
going to get into some of the
battleground states how much does
national polling matter we're gonna
start getting into the internals of a
lot of this stuff but if you want I mean
listen the Kentucky result from last
night is great the Virginia results from
last night are great but if you want to
see a drastic change from years past and
a major major red flag for Republicans
it's that Mississippi one of the reddest
states in the country which they often
win in the gubernatorial races by more
than 30 points they only won by 6 with
voter turnout disproportionately up not
from Republicans but from Democrats and
from Independence terrible news from
Republicans heading into 2020 we'll talk
about 2020 a little bit more if I missed
obviously didn't get to everything that
happened yesterday but if there are
races that you think are important
lenses through which we should be
looking to 2020 that I didn't talk about
today get in touch and I will continue
to cover the results on tomorrow's
program
what's also worse than we could have
ever imagined is the degree to which
Donald Trump and people around him are
desperate to endanger the life really
the lives not only of the Ukraine
whistleblower but of the whistleblowers
family as well now I told you at the
start of the Ukraine whistleblower
Fiasco that Donald Trump and his
acolytes will not stop until the
whistleblower is in danger and it
actually is starting to seem like they
will not stop
until the whistleblower potentially
loses their life Trump has already
referred to the whistleblower as a spy
as a traitor
we know that Trump is working very very
hard to leak the name of the
whistleblower despite whistleblower
protection being a core tenet of the
United States Trump did one of his magus
safeSpace rallies last night in
Lexington Kentucky lexington kentucky
rather the home state of totally toxic
ophthalmologist Senator Rand Paul and
Rand Paul an advocate for privacy an
advocate for the rule of law an advocate
for the Constitution Rand Paul claiming
that they have the whistleblowers name
and the crowd goes wild and imploring
imploring the media to out the
whistleblower printing their name
they're not going to stop until the
whistleblower may be dead
take a look President Trump has great
courage he faces down the fake media
every day
but Congress needs to step up and have
equal courage to defend the president
Hunter Biden made $50,000 a month that's
the definition of corruption we know he
got it only because of his family
connections we also now know the name of
the whistleblower
the whistleblower needs to come before
Congress as a material witness because
he worked for Joe Biden at the same time
hunter Biden was getting money from
corrupt oligarchs I say tonight to the
media do your job and print his name
the crowd cheers that they know the name
of the whistleblower they want him outed
which will of course immediately
endanger not only the life of the
whistleblower but of their family as
well this is the type of thing
that Trump brown nosers like Rand Paul
do when they're on good terms with Trump
but then sometimes those relationships
with Donald Trump go bad and Trump
abandons them they have a falling out
and later they'll say yeah maybe that
was a mistake I don't stand behind
everything I did in support of Trump and
when it comes to Rand Paul it's
particularly hypocritical because Rand
Paul again has been touting his entire
political career he's all about the
Constitution he's all about the
framework that was established in the
United States of America around privacy
rights this has been his entire career
and here is Rand Paul privacy advocate
Rand Paul rule of law advocate Rand Paul
talking about
let's violate the framework upon which
our country is based in violation of the
whistleblowers privacy rights for his
political gain to ingratiate himself
with Donald Trump who he's been golfing
with regularly another touch by the way
I don't know if if you were listening
you didn't see this if you watched the
clip we just played
they gave the trumpet standing on the
stage behind Trump t-shirts that say
read the transcript which is Trump's
continued reference to the idea that if
you just look at the transcript it
completely vindicates Donald Trump of
any wrongdoing now of course they didn't
release a transcript of the phone call
they released what seemed to be about
seven or eight minutes of conversation
from a phone call that we know lasts at
a half hour which is by the way
extraordinarily incriminating of Trump
Trump is not a cognitively strong enough
to recognize that the trance quote
transcript even the small pieces of it
that were published does not vindicate
Trump its incriminating but they gave
everybody on stage and shirts that say
release that read the transcript now
what they are asking for here in terms
of media go ahead and out the
whistleblower this runs counter to the
law now you can feel that politically
the whistleblower should be outed you
might take that position as a political
position but the whistleblower is
protected by law and Donald
Trump and Rand Paul claimed to be about
law and order and law and order says
that the whistleblowers identity must be
protected so they're all jumping on this
messaging here is Donald Trump two days
ago saying the same thing exposed the
whistleblower which any reasonable
person interprets as instantly
endangering the life of the
whistleblower
well the whistleblower gave a very
inaccurate report and as you know
certain of the media released
information about a man that they said
was the whistleblower I don't know if
that's true or not but what they said is
he's an Obama person it was involved
with Brennan Susan Rice which means
Obama he but he was like a big a big
anti Trump person hated Trump and they
said terrible things now I don't know if
it's true or not but that was reported
by some of the media so you'll have to
find out I don't know why the media is
not on it because the whistleblower gave
a very inaccurate report about my phone
call my phone call was perfecta it was
totally appropriate but he gave a report
he or she but according to the
newspapers it's a he they think they
know they know who it is you know who it
is you just don't want to report it CNN
knows who it is but you don't want to
report it the wit and you know you'd be
doing the public a service if you did
the whistleblower gave a false report
and because of that false report people
thought bad things were done and then
you had chip go out and speak before
Congress and before the American people
and give a false story he made up a
story and then I released after after
all this was done I released and
everybody said he didn't do anything
wrong but the whistleblower should be
this is an incitement of violence
against the whistleblower I mean listen
you can say Trump is not personally
saying attack the whistleblower but it
is in practice an incitement of violence
against the whistleblower because
they're being exposed immediately in
dangers their life it's also
increasingly irrelevant though okay and
let me explain this to you we have
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh we
have according to the spectator which I
talked about earlier today seven new
whistleblowers we have Donald Trump's
partial transcript itself which is
massively incriminating
so the initial whistleblower becomes
less and less relevant every time that
their claims are corroborated think
about when someone calls the police and
reports a burglary or a crime of some
kind
and they want anonymity but the police
show up and they investigate and they
find other witnesses that saw the same
thing they find evidence that
corroborates that initial anonymous
report it no longer matters who
originally made that first anonymous
report the whistleblower that Donald
Trump wants outed is increasingly
irrelevant as we have witnesses who were
in the room who heard the July 25 phone
call between Trump and Ukrainian
president zalenski we have Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh so Trump is
doing what he does best it's really the
only thing he can do which is deflect
the blame try to distract the media make
the story an adjudication of the initial
whistleblower and you know that this is
not going well because whenever you hear
others come to Trump's defense like Rand
Paul in this case they don't defend
Trump's actions because Trump's actions
are not defensible they attack the
whistleblower they go to the media and
there's another important element here
that we have to consider by doing this
they are also intimidating future
potential whistleblowers and I've said
this before when you make a big show of
publicly calling for the outing of a
whistleblower you are sending a message
to others who know things that says if
you come forward we will publicly on the
national stage try to out you and your
life will be at risk and the life of
your family will be at risk it's sick
anti-american and we can't allow them to
get away with it we really can't I
believe that the fastest recourse the
world were a year from the election it's
just 12 months and then we can end this
national nightmare of what will have
been a four-year nightmare I believe
that that is still the fastest path make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram for more of this story
and others at david pakman show give us
a follow and while you're there follow
me on instagram at david pakman as well
the level of panic and desperation that
has arrived at the inner reaches of
Donald Trump's mind hit a sort of climax
over the weekend and we're gonna dig
into a few of the different ways in
which this happened one is Donald Trump
inventing an absolutely absurd
conspiracy theory in another one of
these wild anti impeachment outbursts
this one contained the suggestion of
crimes for Republicans to commit also
involving Adam Schiff allegedly editing
documents from so-called never Trump
errs and there's so much going on here
that you really have to research each
element of the conspiracy to even have a
shot at understanding what Trump is
trying to argue never mind that it makes
no sense so let's look at it piece by
piece it was a three tweet outburst but
I think we're better sort of looking at
it tweet by tweet and really breaking
down what's being said here and what's
important is we can't allow this stuff
to become mainstream talking points
because there's just nothing to it and
very quickly trumpets latch on to the
stuff and it's like you can't turn back
the floodgates or unring the Bell so
first tweet quote if shifty Adam Schiff
who is a corrupt politician who
fraudulently made-up what I said on the
call is allowed to release transcripts
of the never Trump errs and others that
are and were interviewed he will change
the words that were said to suit the
Dems purposes so put aside the
grammatical bastardization of the
English language that's going on here
and go through assertion by assertion
there's no evidence of Adam Schiff being
corrupt this is straight out of Sean
Hannity's playbook Sean Hannity's the
Fox News host and friend of Donald Trump
who's been claiming that Schiff is a
corrupt leaker
but there's no evidence of that of
course they don't care about evidence it
just makes a nice story second Adam
Schiff hasn't made up anything that
Donald Trump said on the call what we
know Trump said because Trump released
it in a partial transcript which Trump
thought vindicated him was actually
extraordinarily incriminating and we
know that most of the call was missing
from the partial transcript that was
released number three
Trump talking about transcripts of
so-called never Trump errs Trump is
referring to the fact that there are
allegedly people involved in the Ukraine
Fiasco who allegedly didn't support
Trump in 2016 which is most people in
the country remember Trump lost the
popular vote to Hillary and half the
country didn't vote so like 76 77
percent of the country did not vote for
Donald Trump in 2016 that doesn't make
them corrupt it doesn't make them
untrustworthy and then again alleging
without any evidence that Adam Schiff
will manipulate transcripts which is a
horrible allegation and there is no
evidence of that whatsoever second tweet
Republicans should give their own
transcripts of the interviews to
contrast with shifts manipulated
propaganda House Republicans have
nothing to do with Shifty's rendition of
those interviews he is a proven liar
leaker and freak who is really the one
who should be impeached again using the
false basis that Adam Schiff faked
transcripts to then suggest Republicans
effectively forged their own transcripts
right this would these would be crimes
Trump I'm sure if asked would say no no
no shift faked transcript so I'm
recommending Republicans release the
real transcripts this is bogus
if Republicans release alternative
transcripts they would be doctored they
would be what Trump is accusing Adam
Schiff of having published and those
would be crimes okay and then again
throwing in that ship is a proven liar
leaker and freak for which there is no
evidence and just a reminder this is the
President of the United States talking
this way about other elected officials
high-ranking ones at that this is a
President of the United States acting
like a lying petulant child who is by
the way extremely unbalanced I mean
think about it if Ana if you had a
nine-year-old and you found out that in
school they were behaving
this way in treating other classmates in
this way they would be sent for a mental
health evaluation they would be screened
for personality disorders in our case
it's the President of the United States
who's behaving that way and then the
third of the three tweets in this
unhinged rant Trump saying quote false
stories are being reported that a few
Republican senators are saying that
President Trump may have done a quid pro
quo but it doesn't matter there is
nothing wrong with that it is not an
impeachable event perhaps so but read
the transcript
there is no quid pro quo well there's
actually a very well sourced story in
The Washington Post which says that it's
true there are Republican senators
considering acknowledging that there was
a quid pro quo now that doesn't mean
they're going to abandon Trump they will
say what Trump is saying which is a quid
pro quo is just fine which is what
Donald Trump also does Trump says even
if there was a quid pro quo it doesn't
matter there's nothing wrong with it and
yet again the transition from it
definitely didn't happen - even if it
happened it would be okay it's not a
crime it's not impeachable that
transition starts to take place and
that's a transition we're
well-acquainted with in the Trump era
this man must be removed he must be
removed and the way to do it at this
point still most likely is just voting
him out in November of 2020 it's really
important in this era of constant sort
of political scandal and in reality it's
it's almost an era of constant scandal
fatigue not to let the storylines of
this administration just fade away
without follow-up and one of those
stories is the wall right Donald Trump's
wall with Mexico which we now learned
can be defeated with a hundred dollars
saw available at any hardware store
so remember Donald Trump promised a wall
across the entire us-mexico border by
the end of his first term obviously a
joke it's not going to happen it always
was a joke it was never going to happen
but Donald Trump and his followers are
trying to claim that the wall is being
built Trump says it's being built the
truth is that there was previously
approved money to repair and replace
some aged parts of the wall and it is
being done with the version of the wall
that Donald Trump likes or says is quote
virtually impenetrable so another
element of this is the strength of the
wall and the ways in which the wall can
be defeated and it turns out that the
wall Trump wants to build is a total
farce
it is not virtually impenetrable it is
very easily defeated and in fact border
agents and officials recently told The
Washington Post that $100 saw that you
can get at any hardware store can cut
right through the wall some of these
rebuilt repaired wall sections were done
with Trump's version of the wall which
has steel bollards and it has a 30 foot
a series of 30 foot tall panels so
smugglers have been carrying around $100
saw and just cutting through the steel
ball ERDs and then you push the panels
forward and you walked right through
Donald Trump's virtually impenetrable
wall which he called the rolls-royce of
walls it sounds more like the Trump
Tower of walls given its shoddy nature I
think that's the better analogy for the
quality of the construction that I would
use now unfortunately this is what
happens when you let xenophobia blind
you and your followers you end up
putting all of your eggs in one basket
in this case it's the basket of a wall
that doesn't really work and in the
basket of obsolete technology that does
nothing to address the underlying
reality of why people are trying to come
to the United States which is really
what we should be working on if we want
to solve this problem but it turns out
that it can also be defeated with a
hundred dollar tool look at any time in
history and look at the various ways the
myriad ways in which walls have been
defeated look at Troy look at I'm
forgetting other historical examples
offhand but there are many of them now
you can argue the point of the wall
isn't that it has to actually be
impenetrable it just has to delay people
long enough that border patrol can show
up wait a second
you're shifting the goal posts to say
that we're going to spend 20 billion 25
whatever it's going to be and it's not
meant to stop $100 saw it's just meant
to delay people so that Border Patrol
can show up doesn't a river also delay
people long enough that Border Patrol
should be able to show up in all cases
because we've already got that at much
of the border the wall is not pragmatic
the wall is a monument to xenophobia
it's a monument to political promises
and it's not being built that's the most
important thing it is quite literally a
boondoggle and by the way I'll remind
you it's not just a hundred dollars saw
that can defeat the wall the wall has
been scaled and passed over as well but
this is also altom utley not about that
this is an example of feelings over
facts the fact that the wall will cost
tens of billions of dollars and not
solve anything the fact that the wall
can be defeated with a hundred dollar
tool the facts don't matter the feeling
that trumpets get by seeing Trump talk
about the wall and promise the wall of
Trump being big and strong and powerful
and that it'll stop people from coming
in in some complete fantasy world that
supersedes the facts and the people who
shout about we should pay attention to
facts over feelings are the ones who are
being destroyed by their own feelings
while ignoring the facts and yet again
another embarrassment $100 saw defeating
the wall the wall is barely a
conversation anymore for Republicans of
course because it was yet another one of
Donald Trump's massive failures but
we're not going to forget about it today
I have both incredibly tremendous
numbers for Donald Trump coming up in a
sort of different context but also
devastating numbers for Donald Trump so
we're a year out from the election
yesterday we talked about how more than
likely this is going to be an election
like most elections that comes down to
the results in some key battleground
states we looked yesterday at how Donald
Trump is faring in particular states in
head-to-head matchups against the three
frontrunners in the Democratic primary
Joe Biden Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders fine Trump is doing quite poorly
in these battleground states against
Biden and Bernie and he's actually doing
pretty
well in those battleground states
against Elizabeth Warren however let's
at least briefly look at the national
numbers because if the national numbers
are even close to accurate we could be
heading towards a historic election
defeat for Donald Trump so let's take a
look Joe Biden in a hypothetical matchup
is leading Donald Trump nationally by 17
according to a new Washington Post poll
Elizabeth Warren is leading Trump by 15
and Bernie Sanders right in there
leading Trump at 14 now these are truly
stunning numbers and of course we've not
seen a popular vote victory in a
presidential campaign by 14 15 or 17 for
a very very long time offhand I don't
remember when the last time was
according to the same poll even mayor
Pete Budaj and Kamala Harris are leading
Trump but not by as much so let's go
through it piece by piece as I said
yesterday do I expect Donald Trump to
lose the popular vote in 2020 by 14
points by 15 points by 17 points I don't
expect that I believe some people who
today say they would vote for a Democrat
will end up voting for Donald Trump
either out of fear or due to propaganda
or incumbency bias I believe that it is
going to tighten and indeed a lot of
that lopsided popular vote is going to
end up coming out of big blue states
like California as we saw in 2016 if you
look at polling today in states that are
expected to be the difference makers we
already looked at those numbers
yesterday it is much tighter you're
looking at four to six you know even
much much narrower margins but still if
the popular vote is even half as
lopsided as this polling suggests we
could have an unprecedented
unprecedented defeat for Donald Trump in
November of 2020 but Donald Trump could
also get himself reelected even losing
the popular vote by three four even five
or six points there are models where
Trump loses the popular vote by five
points but still wins the electoral
college although as you get to 567 it
starts to become more and more unlikely
that you could lose the popular vote by
so much
and still managed to win the electoral
college but these are not numbers that
anyone who is on our side should be
counting on or seeing as a signal that
we should relax and not worry about the
outcome because remember the letdown
that was 2016 every single person should
be voting no matter where you vote now
one good sign for the anti-trump
movement is that if you look at the
internals of how this big rift between
Trump and the Democratic frontrunner has
opened up of course Democrats
overwhelmingly voting against Trump of
course Republicans overwhelmingly voting
for Trump but independents have been
slowly shifting away from Donald Trump
and that's a good sign for the
anti-trump movement Republicans mostly
love the guy
Democrats mostly hate the guy and it's
going to be a turnout game but
independent voters shifting to be more
and more against Trump is a bad sign for
him and a good sign for Democrats lastly
we really need to not underestimate that
even if these numbers remain this way
for the next year even if we get out the
vote there can be another 11th hour
Comey letter or you know some equivalent
to it obviously it's not going to be
Comey in 2020 but some equivalent to it
the effect of strategic algorithmic
online advertising could be a difference
maker the voter suppression tactics that
are employed by Republicans at the state
level so the real risk here is
overconfidence which could put Donald
Trump in office for another four years
and what we need to do in order to sort
of fight back or overwhelm those factors
that at the last minute could help
Donald Trump is turnout on our side
needs to be so high that none of those
things end up making a difference so
register to vote help other people
register to vote remind people to
register to vote confirm that you were
registered to vote if you believe that
you are report any registration
irregularities or voter purges to both
the media and your local election
officials now not October 29th not on
election day or the day before we've got
to get on this now and if all of
things come together then we may be able
to remove Donald Trump and you know 17
points down in a poll to Joe Biden who
cares we don't need to win by 17 it
doesn't matter if we can trust those
polls we just need to win and that is
what the focus needs to be for the next
I guess it's like 359 days or something
like that the countdown is very much on